en effet ce matin jean marie villemin a
été libéré il est toujours placé sous
contrôle judiciaire
elle est inculpée du meurtre de son
cousin bernard laroche qu'il considérait
soudé à l'époque comme responsable de la
mort de son trio nba
c'est la cinquième fois qu'il demandait
une mise en liberté provisoire
ils appellent notamment 84 effondré en
2004 ont empoisonné par les gendarmes
ces tours
en plus d'éléments déterminants après
trois mois de détention le jeu doit
libérer bernard laroche jean-marie 30 de
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de dijon a des sonates un kiné
l'agressive libre de ses mouvements
de quoi choquer traite de la main la
veuve de bernard laroche cette décision
comporte une attaque de la part du
président de la chambre d'accusation et
de la majorité la chambre d'accusation à
l'égard de mes clients par leur
d'arguments méprisable
sincèrement la mise en scène et
concernant le recours à la médiatisation
ce sont des problèmes qui appelle
réflexion car vous savez qu'il interdit
à des magistrats baisse prononcée par
partialité et je crains que là la barre
et été franchi
assortie d'un contrôle judiciaire qui
leur donnait magistrats de la chambre
d'accusation de la cour d'appel de dijon
permettra la poursuite de l'information
de l'assassinât du petit grégory dans le
calme sans précipitation